have you ever done anything in your long
and storied career that you consider
specifically to be in bad taste as you
look back on it maybe at the time you
thought it was a good play but you look
back on you think that was in bad taste
well sometimes like in stand-up I'll do
jokes that are then I like one town is
doing this thing in San Francisco and
they were all gay people in the audience
they told me so I figured out so I
figured I'd do stuff about gay people so
that they could relate to love that I
was talking about cuz I went to this gay
pride parade and I saw in it there were
these old men and old ladies like with
these signs that said we are proud of
our gay son you know and so I was saying
that's an odd thing to be proud of you
know because it's not an achievement you
know it's not like something you work
all your life to be gay or anything like
that and I just wanted I just I had a
hard time believing that is 50 60
year-old men are actually bragging you
know it worked like there hey Bill you
know my kid oh my god we're proud of him
Johnny he graduated from Harvard you
know the first in his class you know
what I mean
now he's articling over to love him and
oh yeah he loves [ __ ]
[Applause]
he can't get enough [ __ ] in his mouth as
asses kids always talk I got a picture
of the boy here sucking another man's
[ __ ] I want to show you the maturation
of you as an artist to realize it took
him nine and a half minutes to get her
onto the second [ __ ] stop I want to talk
to you about something because this came
up earlier in the show accidentally
because I didn't know what Norma's gonna
talk about tonight and it's best
sometimes if I don't know but he
mentioned carrot top you are making a
movie with carrot top right I made a
movie with carrot top
okay you've made a movie of carrot top
it's it's not out yet
no can you put the picture up of carrot
top again just so we can all see him oh
there it is again yeah alright okay
places do a movie with carrot top
that's where I'm going my friend this
begs the question now why a movie with
carrot top why a movie character I know
I don't know much about carrot top you
know I I don't know much about him I'm a
little jealous cuz he's a red-haired
comedian and I felt like maybe you'd do
a movie with me first then move on to
carrot top then to Ralph Malph from
Happy Day you know sort of the three
there's an order in which you do movies
with the redheads
what what's he like first of all he's
extraordinarily sweet nice guy he really
is and he worked very hard and he was
adorable and he works with a lot of
props and stuff to write a movie oh and
the movie they took his props props away
that's a bad time to suddenly take away
everything you know about comedy you
know you've been using props now all
your life for comedy now we're going to
take him away when you make your first
movie was he okay though with it he was
cool he was great you did a wonderful
job you ever seen were you and you and
him in break lots of making out oh for
God's sake
all right it's like nine 1/2 weeks but
carrot top Wow
[Applause]
[ __ ] premature ejaculator
[Applause]
this is what happened you know what
happened he said I'm gonna have seconds
and I'm looking at him cuz I know
there's more and I wait and wait and I
see the glimmer in the eye and then bang
I thought you're going to crack [ __ ]
but no but what's the movie going to be
called yeah what's that if it's got
carrot top in it you know how to good
name for it be
what's that norm box-office poison
thorne-smith the girl sitting to your
left is in the movie she's a beautiful
lady and a talented nice joke yes as
evidenced by her appearance on our rival
show alright well there's this two-hour
season finale of Melrose Place there's
this movie coming out yeah title
undetermined at this point yeah I'm
gonna the board Wow alright do something
with that usually I got the board is
spelled Bo are Edie
[Applause]
hey for the ninth consecutive year Nick
JetBlue air
well airline ranked first for
satisfaction among all North American
Airlines but you know what ranked least
some satisfaction 9/11 Airlines what a
terrible name for an airliner reminds me
of that tragedy I know what yeah I don't
laugh I know I walked through blood and
bones in the streets of Manhattan trying
to find my brother
Jesus yeah he was in northern Canada and
of course it was very inspiring to see
President Clinton up here on crutches
making a speech I mean I thought that
was just as amazing you know I mean it's
been difficult for the president you
know he can't jog now and he needs help
getting around and he's still you know
he's still occasionally suffers great
pain you know on the upside you got your
medical marijuana so that's
you must inhale sir it's the only way
you're gonna get better it's
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and there's Charles Woodson how about
that I want to season here
[Applause]
he became the first defensive player to
win the Heisman Trophy congratulations
Charles that is something that no one
can ever take away from you unless you
kill your wife and a waiter in which
case
one
[Applause]